so i guess like growing up uh in japan
or
not so much well you're spending a lot
of your childhood in japan right is
there like
i don't know i feel because like as
someone who also
spent a lot of his childhood in japan
there's like
certain types of i guess like anime or
shows or like manga
where it's like it's only really like
read or watched by people who were
in that kind of situation you know i
mean like a lot of like the slice of
life [ __ ] like
someone who did it yeah like i said like
um that was like my major thing whenever
i'd come to japan
i would record those shows and i'd bring
it back i
throughout the year yeah it sounds so
bizarre to me like the thought of just
like
going away to a foreign country stuff
it's rich right yeah
everybody thought like i was like hella
rich because every summer it's like oh
i'm vacationing in japan i'm summering
in japan
but it's not it was kanji test and then
smash cuts
it must be like is it is it weird like
going to a foreign country just having a
com
like i mean even then back then japan
was even more isolated at that point
right it must be so bizarre
just having to go back and forth but
forth between those two feel like no one
in my school
went anywhere foreign and like studied
there but that's that's because
were there any asian people in your
school one asian person came to my
school as i was leaving
i'm not i wish i was joking i literally
went to i i grew up in like the whitest
part of like the whole
country and like there was like never
any uh like foreign people
i was only like one of two asian kids in
my whole like
school career yeah i was the only one i
i was i was the only one as well and
like i grew up in brighton which is now
seen as like the very
progressive city it's like the gay
capital of it wasn't yeah it was the gay
capital i don't know if it still is but
it was like
now it's seen as the very progressive
city in england um
but it wasn't like that when i was
growing up i'll tell you that because
like yeah i was
literally the only asian person in my
school my school wasn't small we had
like
in in sixth form we had like 800 people
class had like 600 something people and
by by high school there were a few more
but like middle school elementary school
like
or i'm sorry secondary school or i get
confused about
i get confused as well
secondary school but i like i just call
it high school now
by american culture but uh yeah
um i don't know it wasn't really weird
for me i knew
i was i got to step into a different
world every summer and also like i love
my family and because
my mom was able to bring me back every
year it kind of stayed
should we bring you back like sorry
didn't get the plane tickets
yeah like i don't know i felt very
connected so it wasn't
that stark of a thing like it was just a
thing for me right like oh every summer
i go to japan
like every winter i go to japan and
maybe it's because i also went two times
a year that's also why
i didn't feel like i only got to go once
you are lucky though we weren't in the
same
class i'd have been like rayna rain
[ __ ] tell me everything how did they
go what are you doing
you'd be into japan dude i was yeah as a
kid yeah i was yeah
always i mean i guess that's why i'm
here right now right now
yeah ever since a kid i always just
thought that like asia was super cool
and that like because
to europe it's like the furthest place
right which is funny right because
people in asia are like oh man europe is
so
nervous yeah yeah yeah i mean that now i
really like europe when i was going i'm
like mom i don't want to go to [ __ ]
romania i don't want to go to bulgaria
or whatever like i came to like asia i
want to go see
because it all [ __ ] looks the same in
europe but it doesn't but
as a kid it all feels the same of course
of course i remember
when i was like maybe 12 or something
we were shown big bird goes to japan
in one of our history classes oh no and
one two three
is ichini song was really huge and then
everybody came to me all of a sudden and
they're like
do you have a kimono
like do you pay in yearn like they
didn't know what the [ __ ]
like that was i think the first like
super fascination that people had and i
was like really
a big bird literal big bird
made you interested in japan and they're
like really ohio which is a state in the
us
ohio means good morning
[ __ ] language than you bro like
yeah so that was my experience growing
up so there wasn't like there wasn't
like kids who were like into the culture
that were like brain
i got to ask you things you know i had
um a parent
that was very into japan um
sounds weird yeah and like she'd really
want her daughter to be friends with
japan and she like always wanted to have
tea with my mom um green tea
and of course of course that's all we
drink
yeah she was like matcha um but yeah
that was that was like the only
um hyper concentrated interest i think
anybody had
i did not care for this girl like
man yeah it sucks i always wanted to
learn more about it but you were just so
limited what you could find because i
didn't know anyone
on the internet i didn't know anyone who
knew anyone yeah even through the
internet as well it all came from like
second third hand accounts yeah
right you can't get to like really know
yeah but yeah
so just like read forums and have to
like piece things together
i think this is yeah like i i i think
this is like the right thing i'm not
really sure but like i'll ask i look
around because you know i always just
loved
games as well and games were like a huge
thing i was like where these games come
from
um yeah so gaming was the other thing i
think that brought attention to my
nationality that was really like when
ddr came everyone's like
wow japan like can you are you can you
sing
butterfly or like candy like that was
that was it
that was a big that's horrifying yeah i
know i know were you into details
that probably that probably didn't help
them
reinforcing the stereotype my god i'm
fine i'll spit fire geez
i feel like [ __ ] i mean i'm like do you
eat sushi every day
oh my god